a major incident has been declared on
merseyside with one man dead another
injured and three men arrested under the
terrorism act
just before 11 o'clock on remembrance
sunday a car exploded into flames
outside the liverpool women's hospital
the man who died was a passenger in the
car the driver escaped with injuries and
was taken to hospital
as counter-terrorism police took charge
of the investigation armed officers were
seen operating at rutland avenue a mile
away from the scene of the explosion
residents have been told to stay indoors
i think some people have like attempted
to leave on the road but then they have
to be told that they're not allowed to
come back so they'll have to
you know just to stay out of the road
yeah we've heard police shouting at
people to stay inside if they've tried
to leave the house we've heard them like
just been ordered to stay inside
basically
two miles away boiler street in
kensington was also sealed off police
confirmed three men aged 21 26 and 29
were arrested in the kensington area
under the terrorism act
there are three cordons in liverpool to
residential streets and a major hospital
counter-terrorism police northwest say
they're working at a rapid pace to
establish the circumstances of what
happened the counter-terrorism unit says
it continues to keep an open mind about
the cause of the explosion and is
working closely with merseyside police